comme tous les chefs d'états et vous
n'êtes pas le premier vous avez décidé
de supprimer un impôt qui vous
appartient pas et je le dis d'autant
plus volontiers que andré laignel et moi
même nous avons appartenu à des
gouvernements qui ont fait exactement la
même chose et je le dis encore plus
volontiers que le rassemblement des
mères leur à ce moment où la mairie
publiques pendant trois jours ici à
paris est née justement contre un état
et un président de la république qui
avait décidé de supprimer un impôt qui
lui appartenait pas c'est l octroi qui
allait financer les caisses des recettes
communales pour permettre d'accompagner
les services publics et le développement
des territoires
donc il n'y a pas grand chose de nouveau
enfin comme à cette époque tous les
maires et à chacune des périodes tous
les maires ont revendiqué il n'y a pas
de raison vous ayez un traitement de
faveur et nous maintenons cette
revendication bien légitime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pourrais longuement évoquée au fond
les arguments contraire de ceux qui ont
été développés pour supprimer la taxe
d'habitation je n'y reviendrai pages
pourrait juste dire que si c'était un
pouvoir d'achat supplémentaire c'est
plutôt un pouvoir d'achat pour ceux qui
en ont déjà car je rappelle que déjà 20
% des gens étaient des grèves et de la
taxe d'habitation que 23 % étaient
exonérés partiellement ou totalement que
vous aviez donc déjà 43 % des français
qui la paient pas et donc l'effort qui
était portée sur l'évolution de la
fiscalité locale était porté sur à peine
la moitié des français qui justifie l
argument d'injustice que vous avez
repris à votre compte et après tout ça
une certaine logique en face ils
regardent tous les autres impôts y
compris ceux de l'état on arrive à peu
près à la même conclusion
il y avait des choix à faire vous avez
fait celui qui nous concerne nous avons
essayé de corriger avec votre
gouvernement
ce mal la solution vous retenez sur le
transfert du foncier le moindre mal pour
les communes
mais il soulève d'autres questions
puisque l'injustice montré du doigt
concernant la taxe d'habitation est
exactement la même que celle qui repose
sur l'assiette du foncier donc le débat
sur l'avenir du foncier d'ores et déjà
poser si l'on considère que le paradigme
idéal c'est de dire c'est un poète a
juste il faut donc le corriger et pour
le corriger il faut le supprimer
deuxième élément on nous dit mais il va
y avoir de la décentralisation et là on
aimerait vous entendre monsieur le
président de la république très
fortement et très puissamment comme en
retirant le foncier au département qui
perdent leur autonomie fiscale et
gestion on peut imaginer garantir la
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales et de l'autre offrir des
garanties de financement sachant qu'il
ya toujours la dualité des lois de
finances et qui créeront naturellement
une instabilité sur cette fiscalité
locale donc on va repousser on vous fait
confiance à l'échelle de votre mandat
mais en revanche nous avons évidemment
de sérieuses interrogations notamment
sur un débat qui monte
concernant là encore les impôts de
production on peut pas d'un côté ne plus
avoir la taxe d'habitation
de l'autre le transfert du foncier ou
statec les départements garantissent la
solidarité et à la fin parler de libre
administration des collectivités locales
et au milieu se dire que dans cette eau
no money financières et fiscales que
nous perdons
devons faire plus mieux et être à vos
côtés pour répondre à toutes ces
problématiques
c'est un sujet d'importance et c'est un
sujet sur lequel votre position sur la
lecture de la décentralisation sera
évidemment essentiel ce seront mes mots
de conclusion avec territoire unis nous
avons offert il ya un an
une main tendue certes de manière un peu
ferme mais après tout nous sommes les
poils à gratter de tout état et notre
problématique n'est pas d'accompagner
tel ou tel gouvernement
notre problématique est de garantir
l'efficacité des services publics de
proximité dans une logique de
décentralisation et nous faisons partout
le constat qu'en europe les forces qui
nourrissent et qui développe ses besoins
de libertés locales sont en mouvement
partout et y compris en france les
consultations référendaires en italie il
ya deux ou trois ans ont marqué ce
besoin liberté avec plus d'autonomie
encore pour les provinces je mets de
côté le cas espagnol qui est un cas
singulier mais qui dérouille quand même
beaucoup de cet état d'esprit cette
philosophie modèle allemand avec son
modèle fédéral a créé aussi des
garanties d'autonomie alors vous pouvez
me dire oui mais transfert de l'argent
de l'état fédéral vers les collectivités
vont failli sont aussi des moyens de
levier ils ont un système de banques
indépendantes régionalisée et donc ils
ont plus de moyens de cohérence de
politique industrielle d'activités de
services et développement des
collectivités locales chez nous cette
expression de liberté locale peut
prendre des formes différentes et notre
histoire le montrer et le prouve
vous avez entendu ce message puisque
vous avez repris monsieur prix dans la
république à votre compte
dans les conclusions vous avez tiré du
grand débat au lendemain du
mouvement des gels et jaune dans
l'encadrement de ce grand débat vous
avez fixé ce besoin et cet appel à une
nouvelle décentralisation nous sommes
d'accord sur le calendrier
nous n'allons pas gêner les élections
municipales les candidats les électeurs
sur des problématiques de cette nature
mais nous les candidats ou les mères
nous allons profiter de ce temps
municipal pour être à l'écouté des
besoins de transfert de compétences de
proximité pour savoir si à tel endroit
et sur tel sujet l'état et plus
pertinents et si à tel endroit et sur
d'autres sujets c'est la commune le
département ou la région
ce sera un nouveau grand débat
démocratique électorale qui nous
permettra je l'imaginent d'offrir une
plateforme supplémentaire pour ensuite
la mise en place des groupes sous votre
autorité
et puis une fois pendant à discuter du
calendrier et de la méthode il faudra
qu'on fixe ensemble les objectifs le
temps que vous souhaiterez sera le nôtre
mais nous devons avoir des réflexions
sur l'emploi nous devons avoir des
réflexions sur la formation
professionnelle et l'apprentissage
nous devons avoir des réflexions sur le
développement économique nous devons
avoir des réflexions sur la santé et la
cohésion sociale à travers justement la
solidarité porté par les départements et
nous devons avoir aussi une ambition sur
tout ce qui concerne la proximité cela
va du tourisme au logement en passant
par le sport ou la culture la culture
ces trois piliers c'est le patrimoine
c'est l'aide à la création c'est l'égal
accès pour tous à la culture de tout
cela les maires sont capables d'apporter
d'accompagner des politiques publiques
de proximité
nous sommes disponibles pour ouvrir un
grand débat qui sera une chance pour
nous administrer usagers du service
public contribuables mais qui peut être
si vous me le permettez charles emmanuel
macron une grande chance pour l'état à
l'échelle du mandat qui vous est confié
par les français pour atteindre le
double objectif de remuscler l'état là
où il est attendu et protecteur et
d'offrir des libertés locales où elles
sont devenues nécessaires